(whimsical music)
- No.
- Oh yeah.
(laughing)
Never?
- No.
- I'd see straight guys I'd
like to do all the time.
- Yes.
- Whew, man.
- 1000% like, a lot.
- Ah, it's my curse.
I fall in love with
straight men every day.
- Uh, yeah.
- Yeah, but not necessarily
because they're straight?
- No.
- It's more if they're hot.
- I've never like, (gasping)
he's straight.
It's taboo.
That makes him hotter to me.
- Yeah.
- It's just like, I'm
attracted to all men.
- If a straight guy is hot,
even if they were gay,
they'd still be hot.
- Over time, I've figured out
that if somebody is straight,
it's actually a turn off for me?
I kinda lose sexual desire for somebody
if our sexualities aren't compatible.
- Surely you've had a straight guy friend
where you're like, yeah, I'd hit that.
- Yeah, he's sort of attractive.
Ah, dude, you're trying
to poison me over here.
I guess, okay, yeah.
- I'm just trying to get
the truth out of you.
- I guess I look at straight men
the same way I look at women.
Like I can appreciate your beauty,
but I don't really wanna do anything.
(whimsical music)
- Hell, yes, I've been attracted to women.
As I've gotten older,
I've realized that I'm
attracted to a manly man,
and like a cute, feminine women.
- I like a curvy lady.
- Even now, I look at women,
I'm like, yeah, I think
I could get on board.
- As a kid, i was like,
I'm the gayest thing on Earth.
And now, as an adult,
I'm like, I'm hanging out
with my girlfriends alone,
and it's making me feel like
I wanna kiss you right now,
and I'm very confused.
- Nope.
- Jennifer Lopez.
- You'd do J-Lo?
- No, I wasn't sexually attracted.
Oh, okay.
- I thought Britney Spears was hot.
I've never wanted to
have sex with a woman.
- Britney Spears.
I had a whole wall of photos of her,
and I started to grow up,
and I was like, I think it's just
that I wanted to be them,
not that I want them.
- Definitely always
appreciated women's beauty.
I've never been sexually attracted.
- And I think girls are attractive.
I'll definitely check some out,
and be like, oh, damn,
like she's gorgeous.
I never look at them
sexually and was like, damn.
- You never want to go to there.
- Yeah.
(whimsical music)
8th grade, for a week.
I did like her,
but then she told me
she was only dating me
because she wanted my
best friend, and so, yeah.
- I have dated a woman before.
- I had a fake two week relationship
with a girl in 8th grade, and it was bad.
- I went on a couple dates with a girl
my freshman year of college.
It seemed like the thing to do.
- The thing to do.
(laughing)
College, you gotta go
on a date with a girl.
(whimsical music)
- No, I don't watch straight porn.
- No.
- Yeah.
- Yes, as a joke.
- On accident, when it pops up
as a pop up on my gay porn.
- Occasionally, I will
indulge in a straight porn,
or a threesome.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I've been there.
- 10% of my porn watching
might be straight.
- Might?
Why?
- Sometimes the guy's really hot.
- I mean, I've maybe watched a couple
for a specific guy,
to see what he's up to.
- I can appreciate the storyline.
- There's a really
funny comment thread on,
I think it was Reddit.
What's the one thing you
would take out of porn,
and all the guys said,
the shot of the dude's
butthole in straight porn.
I guess they're doggy style.
The camera goes behind the guy,
and shoots him from behind,
but all you see is a butthole and balls,
and I guess the straight men of Reddit
were not impressed,
and didn't want that.
(upbeat music)
- I've never had sex with a woman,
and I don't think I want to.
- I've never had sex with a woman, no.
- I'm a gold star gay.
- Gold star gay.
- 100% gold star gay.
Will it happen, though?
I don't know.
Maybe.
- Yes, I've had sex with a woman.
It feels good,
and also, sex with men feels good, too.
- No.
The closest I ever was to a vagina
was when I was born.
(upbeat music)
- No.
You can't wake up one day and be like,
my gay past is dead.
- You can maybe find a girl
that you have attraction to,
and for some reason, it just works,
and you are so convinced
that you were just into guys,
but to turn fully,
like all of a sudden, I woke up tomorrow,
and I just want girls now?
No.
- Your sexuality can change naturally.
You can't force a change in sexuality.
That doesn't work.
- I don't think that
conversions of any type
are legit or healthy, or right.
If they happen to explore
other types of sex,
I think that that's perfectly fine,
as long as it is in sync
with what they're feeling.
- Yeah, I would have to agree,
because I would say that
when I first came out,
I was like, I'm gay.
I like men.
That's it.
In the 15 years that I've been out,
my sexual preferences have changed,
and I've actually have found myself
attracted to women,
more so than when I
think I first came out.
- I don't think someone
can make you turn straight.
It has to flow with taste.
One day you might be into
carne asada burritos,
and then you might want a burger.
I don't know.
- You and these food analogies.
- Yeah.
(whimsical music)
- Oh, yes, I have.
Flashbacks in my mind.
(laughing)
holy shi --
- I lost my virginity to a straight guy.
- Oh, right.
- I've never hooked up
with a straight dude.
- I have not.
I am not one of those guys
that can be like, oh hey, straight boy,
straight boy, straight boy, kiss me.
You know, I'm like, hi.
Yeah, I have no game.
- Quite a few times,
I've had guys tell me, in secrecy,
that they liked me,
or had some sort of attraction to me,
but I don't know, man,
like I've never felt about a guy this way,
and like, I don't know,
it's like confusing me, man,
and blah, blah, blah,
and I was like, all right,
but I didn't do anything with them.
A couple times I did,
but sometimes I was like.
(laughing)
A couple times I did.
- Not have full on, penetrative
sex with a straight man,
but I've definitely explored
with them other ways.
- It happened once.
- Tell me all a bout it.
- It was fine.
- Was he just like, let's fuck,
but I'm not into guys?
- I think he wanted to experiment,
to see what it was like,
and I was like, okay.
Did it.
It was nice.
But I think at the end of it,
he was like, oh, I don't know,
like, I tried it.
- I had a curious fellow once,
and he, halfway through,
decided nope, this was not for me.
- It was a lot of responsibility though.
- Right.
Am I giving him the full
gay experience right?
- I think it's important for everyone
just to explore what you like sexually.
- Mm-hmm.
- I think that's what
your early 20s are for,
is just like to try different things.
- Or your late 30s.
- Yeah.
- Whenever you want to try something,
I say try it.
- And that's the only way to know
what you actually like.
- And that's how the cookie crumbles.
(whimsical music)
- Guys always say,
gay guys give better head.
(whimsical music)